reporting in progress
I'm Zoom my name is Stuart Creek
I'm with simply learn and we are the
delivery partner for MIT X pro for this
program so
um let me get started
we'll be talking about the machine
learning for business engineering and
Science Program offered by MIT X pro
are it role simply learning is as a
delivery partner for them
and we're going to be talking about
you a little bit will be asking a few
questions along the way we'll talk about
the impact of machine learning and why
it is
so vitally important to understand that
impact whatever field you may be in
um we'll talk about how this program
works to help you gain that
understanding
uh we'll talk about some of the learner
outcomes from the program
and we'll share with you enrollment
steps and I'll take your questions at
the end so please put questions into the
Q a box
take them from there when we reach that
portion of the webinar
so let's talk about the impact of
machine learning
machine learning is a tool to extend the
human capabilities
we have a world in which the flow of
data has become
exponentially greater than even just a
few years ago
um
experienced during the pandemic
period of time where everyone had to
work remotely or go into non-contact
type of work things had to be done
via the Internet or Via mobile devices
rather than in person and each of those
transactions generates data
moreover The Internet of Things creates
much greater number of potential data
sources
and all of that data has meaning if it's
interpreted correctly
but it's impossible for human beings
to handle all that data to condition it
to process it into a form that can be
analyzed
and from which insights can be driven
derived I'm sorry
and
it's
important to have
an understanding of how Machine Tools
can help you do that
machine learning specifically
allows a automated system to take data
from more sources
build better models
and then
populate those models with data from The
Real World
can be compared against
other measurements so that the
predictive value the prescriptive value
the descriptive value of those models
can all be validated and set up in such
a way that the more data the machine
learning model receives the better
yet
output is in terms of conforming to what
reality is
so
machine learning processes allow
he was a human to
um interpret and use all of that data
that's coming in even though it would be
physically impossible for you to deal
with that directly
Sheen does that the machine handles this
extremely high
rate of data and it turns it into
meaning
so you're able then to to draw insights
and perform tasks that would otherwise
be impossible for you to do
so this is why machine learning is so
vital
in all organizations today and
we use it all of our everyday lives
the most
mundane example being
um when you go on to Amazon to purchase
something
you will get your recommendations of
people
also bought
that is a classic example of machine
learning
pulling in data from all the
transactions that happen on Amazon
pulling in data all the
until that they've gathered about the
individuals who use Amazon
and putting that together to
then provide a profile of you
what you're interested in what you've
purchased in the past and what other
people like you have purchased and what
other people who have purchased the
thing you're buying have also purchased
so all of that
boils down to a set of recommendations
where they feel they have the
greatest possibility of matching need
you have to something they're offering
in order to understand machine learning
in order to be able to utilize it within
your organization
you need to be exposed to a wide range
of different machine learning Concepts
this is not about
learning how to be a machine learning
engineer
through this course
not about learning how to be a
programmer or architect of machine
learning systems
the intent behind this course is to give
you the solid foundation that allows you
to evaluate whether a particular process
that you have in your organization can
benefit from a machine learning
implementation
so
in order to be able to do that you do
need to have
at least a basic understanding of the
different pieces that fit into
the machine learning process so
statistics
mathematics understanding how the models
work where they come from
tools like Python and Matlab Keras and
tensorflow
supervised unsupervised learning
reinforcement learning recommendation
systems as I just described all of these
kinds of Concepts
use cases need to be part of your
repertoire so that you can
understand what is possible to do
relate that to your organizations and
I'm going to ask a question
everyone's here to talk about uh or look
at learning about machine learning
but what has stopped you from doing that
up until this point
so I'm going to open a poll if you
happen to be watching on the streaming
systems you can put answers ABCD
into your comments
and
leave this open for a bit
but what are the reasons why you've
looked at programs like this in the past
and decided not to go ahead with them
numbers are still climbing
all right numbers are slowing down so
I'll give you five more seconds to get
your final answer in
and we're going to close the pole now
I'll share with you the result the top
two reasons that people haven't done a
program like this is they haven't felt
that they would get the Practical
experience that we they would need to
apply to their their career or they
haven't found a program with a
comprehensive curriculum
um and of course
right behind that is
not feeling that you have a time in your
work schedule to fit in a learning
program so let's talk about this program
and
how that works
so MIT X pro online Executive Education
from Massachusetts Institute of
Technology
offers the machine learning for business
engineering and Science Program
and this is a four-month program which
requires a commitment of about four to
six hours a week
it's all delivered online so you can
take it from anywhere you are
you are not required to travel anywhere
you're not required to sequester
yourself in a conference room or lecture
hall or hotel room
um you can take it from your desktop or
laptop you can take much of the content
even from your mobile device so
this allows you to fit that the program
in
to almost any
uh
scheduled lifestyle that you have
um
the
content of the program is delivered both
by some pre-recorded content but also by
online live lectures by MIT faculty and
instructors
who will cover the the different course
content with you in weekly live sessions
that
allow you to interact with the
instructor ask questions interact with
your peers in in the cohort and uh
get your questions answered directly
from the instructor
week as we'll cover the
curriculum is comprehensive it covers a
wide basis for the foundation and
machine learning and a number of the use
cases so we'll talk about that the QR
Code by the way goes to the
home page on the web for this program
and
I'd like to do here
is share with you a little video that
MIT Expo has put together
oops hold on a second let me stop
I'm going to re-share that with sound on
apologize for that
[Music]
you should be able to hear it now this
course is about machine learning
modeling and simulation in the world of
engineering and science data-driven
methods and machine learning are
transforming the
oops sorry
way that Engineers approach modeling and
simulation our collaborators are across
many different domains including
computer Graphics Medical Imaging and
scientific Computing today I'm here to
talk about quantifying risk of extreme
events in complex systems we use the
laws of quantum mechanics and solve them
in physics-based models to understand
the world around us neural networks have
recently proved helpful in addressing
the question of seismic Imaging and
we're also going to be talking a little
bit about hype versus reality what are
the kinds of things we can already do
today and what are the kinds of things
we cannot yet do and maybe with new
development we might be able to do one
day we then aim to peer under the hood
and demystify machine learning let's
begin
foreign
[Music]
and that was just a little introductory
clip that MIT xpro put together
and what we want to talk about is what
you get out of the program
so at the end of the program you'll
receive a certificate of completion
issued by MIT X pro
um certifying that you've completed the
program and cover and mastered all of
the course content
you'll also receive eight continuing
education units you are in a
industry or job requires you to provide
proof of a continuing education either
to your employer or to a regulatory body
you'll need the CEUs
the program provides prove that you're
in an undergoing program of continuing
education to keep your skills current
um
but as I mentioned live online classes
delivered by the MIT faculty and
instructors
and you'll be able to connect with your
peers
through an International Community of
professionals people who are involved
MIT ex Pro learners
let's talk about MIT
MIT is Massachusetts Institute of
Technology it's a 160 year old
institution it has produced almost 100
Nobel Prize winners a number of touring
Award winners in the computer science
field even a number of MacArthur fellows
people who are awarded Gene what are
called genius grants by the MacArthur
Foundation
for uh being just exceptionally
bright and inquisitive human beings
MIT has over 60 research centers labs
and programs so it's very heavily
awaited towards research and
um the MIT Pro
uh program the MIT Pro division
takes that uh academic research and
applied research and turns it into
education for professionals working
professionals so
having MIT X pro on your resume is
something that people will recognize
for this program
you have a certain number of
prerequisites
um we do expect you to have college
level mathematics
which means that you must have taken
those types of courses
um
does not require you to have a
bachelor's degree by the time you enroll
in the program
but you should have some experience if
you can with Matlab which is a
mathematics library for uh
doing numerical analysis and then
we are looking for people who are
working professionals looking to gain
insights into metal applications into
use cases and into how
you can use machine learning in your
organization so
curiosity about the field is one of the
most important prerequisites for this
program
and
asking
real simple question here also just to
get a feeling for who's in the audience
to ask
how much experience you have
are you currently in school are you
fairly new in the workforce
or are you more seasoned
let this run for another 20 seconds or
so please get your answers in
numbers are flattening out so I will
close the poll in five seconds
last chance
all right
so while we have about a third of the
audience who are still in school
um we have more than that who are more
than five years of experience
the
again this is a program that's suitable
across all the categories but
more geared towards people who have some
experience in
industry an understanding of
what their business or what businesses
in general require from
machine learning tools so
keep that in mind we'll move on
talk about how this program prepares you
so this program is uh
provided entirely online and
consists of three
Parts first the orientation session that
gets you familiar with the online
learning environment how to
access your different live courses on
all the support materials case studies
pre-recorded video content all of that
which is in the same online platform
and
from that orientation session you move
into the first course which is the
basics of machine learning modeling and
simulation
um and then second the course goes into
specific use cases
it gives you examples of how machine
learning has been used to solve
different problems
at the end of the process you receive
your certificate
so let's look at course number one
modeling and simulation topics that have
been covered
um
you understand the fundamentals of
modeling and simulation and how
machine learning techniques the modeling
turns data into
insights by recognizing patterns based
on statistics
and how then the patterns can be used
both to
describe what is happening in the real
world
to predict what might happen in the real
world through predictive modeling and
simulation
um
and
even to give prescriptive
recommendations based on what your
stated goals are and what the data is
telling you
um spatial modeling
another aspect which looks at the
relation of data to
mentions in the real world uh
optimization and data driven modeling
are part of the process of machine
learning building up
refining models as data comes in so that
when you follow on to
that direct translation from the
optimization process and how it works in
machine learning and then probabilistic
methods that look at um
how to use the
the ideas of
randomness
and
probability
to refine models and to make
recommendations
you move on to course number two verse
number two is machine learning topics
and use cases
a wide variety saw several several of
the professors in that short clip
talking about the
case studies use cases rather that
they're going to present so things like
um how to engineer and lithon ion
batteries for a longer life Based on
data about their
configuration and Performance Machine
learning for computational Imaging
how to use neural Nets to generate the
missing data gaps in seismic surveys for
oil oil and gas expiration
uh how to use machine learning to
predict
productive capacity of oil and gas
fields and Wells
machine learning
uh geometric representations
um
which has
some fantastic applications up to it
including designing new complex
biological
treatments and drugs through protein
structure mapping
quantifying risk and complex systems
using machine learning
which is extremely important in almost
every field and understanding what
could happen
if something unexpected does happen and
then machine learning for acceleration
computational materials Discovery again
the idea of being able to mine data to
come up with insights about what
compounds are possible
um practical machine learning in
composite design
and
how to use uh information again about
structure and configuration and
performance
to come up with
new design Technologies new tech
Manufacturing Technologies for composite
materials machine learning for data in
assimilation and inverse problems so how
to use machine learning to understand
how to use data better
well
um
also talk about a Capstone project
I don't think that that uh
there will be an extensive Capstone
project in this but
let me talk about the MIT faculty and
instructors and you met a few of them in
the video you met Dr Joseph uh marsuk Dr
Kulik
um
and Dr Bueller
these are all professors
who will be presenting different modules
in the different courses
especially with regard to the
case
use cases in course two you get a broad
variety of use cases from different
areas
um and
they'll be the instructors that you'll
meet with on your week weekly basis they
come in to do their particular topics
again you can see these are all
a senior or Junior faculty members
professors and Associate professors of
their different disciplines from
chemical engineering to Mechanical to
ECS and computer science civil uh
environmental engineering
um
so
this is a prestigious group
of faculty
we'll talk about the learner outcomes
we're going to share with you a few of
the testimonials you'll see a few more
on the program page if you go to that
um
Vivian D'Souza
Incorporated
um
especially like Professor youssef's uh
course content and
so he has glowing things to say about
Professor yusuf's uh
lectures
um we have
Rachel naom who is at Dial Systems which
is an aerospace company
um
and
she points out that
you know your math can be intimidating
especially if it's been a long time
since you've oops since you've taken a
course
in college
um but the structure of this course
brings you back up to speed quickly and
helps you get into that mathematics
Groove so to speak
uh tokakaya who is a himself a professor
of ECS
um allowed him to get more background in
machine learning understanding
um
how Matlab enhanced the understanding of
machine learning rather than
um
more generic python libraries so all of
these people and more who have taken the
course
have
really good things to say about it found
it extremely helpful extremely useful
and above a very mentally and
intellectually stimulating so
based on what we've said so far today
are you interested in taking
this program
you're not a commitment but a level of
Interest
I will leave this open
and we will be covering the cost
and enrollment process shortly so
based on what you've heard so far is
something you want to do
watching the numbers come in
yeah
they're leveling off so you have uh five
seconds left
and we'll close the poll now
so just shy of 90 of our respondents
said that they would be interested
in taking this program which is
fantastic
and I will share with you the enrollment
process
the enrollment steps are very basic
you need to email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net again we're the delivery
partner for mitx Pro for this program
and we administer the admissions
um so we'll
advise you our lending consultant will
advise you on what you need to submit
if you contact us by email with the the
initial inquiry they'll tell you what
you need to send in in order to be
evaluated again you're going to be
looking at your professional background
your mathematics
skills
whether or not you have Matlab
experience and
we'll take that in totality and review
your qualifications determine if you've
got a good chance of success in the
program obviously
we want to take everybody but we really
only want to take especially people who
we know are going to succeed because it
doesn't help anybody to enroll someone
who doesn't have sufficient background
or interest in the subject
just for them to
drop out of the program at some point so
we will evaluate your interest
enthusiasm and ability to succeed in the
program and send you an admission offer
if
you meet those criteria
the program fees are 2 375 dollars of
the four month program
again uh you can finance that with uh
interest free financing at 198 dollars a
month
um so
you don't have to pay the lumps on all
some all at once
we also recommend that you ask your
employer about tuition reimbursement
many companies
will support A4 or at least partially
pay for
their employees to take types of ongoing
education programs
so you need to contact your employer to
see what their policy is and whether
they would pay for the course up front
reimburse you after you complete it or
allow you some portion of the cost so
that policy set by your employer
for more assistance of course reach out
to us at ask us simplylearn.net
we are with me for a moment I will put
that into
the chat window so that you can all have
that at your fingertips
one moment
there it is so in the chat window you
find
the link to the program page on the
website as well as
the ask us at simplylearn.net email
and
we'll move on
for those of you who said you would be
interested in the program
um
it's a quick question how soon would you
like to do that have uh frequent cohorts
don't have the exact date of the next
cohort the people at ask us at Simple
learn.net Learning Consultants there
we'll be able to tell you that
um
but are you interested in joining the
next coming cohort
or maybe one after that
or somewhere further down the road
we'll leave this open for about uh
30 seconds more
and the numbers are still changing
slightly okay I think
get your answer's income and close the
poll in 10 seconds
five four three
two
one
so a little over a third of you said you
would want to either join the next
coming cohort or the one right after
within three months
and for those of you who are looking
further down the road I urge you to
contact ask us at simplylearn.net
so that you can get um your questions
answered and so that you can be
but we can keep in touch with you to let
you know when future cohorts are
happening yeah
other information about the program so
best point we're going to questions and
answers and I'm going to stop sharing my
screen for a moment
as you don't need to stare at that slide
so do bear with me as I go through the Q
a so
not been able to follow along as they've
been presenting
uh we have a question about this
particular webinar today which uh about
whether we provide an attendance
certificate generally speaking we we
don't provide attendance certificates
for these overview program overviews um
so I apologize for that
um
Arthur Khan asks uh
same question okay
and we have a question anonymously for
those who are still studying at
University with no job experience
whatsoever do you recommend this program
is there a specific academic background
that's favorable for the learning
process of machine learning
uh so we would
recommend this program as ideal for
people who have been working
um
and have that experience
but we it is something that that would
be valuable to you
if you're still studying University if
you have the requisite mathematics
background
studied
calculus statistics
that type of thing and especially if
you've used some of the tools like
Matlab and Python Programming
those are the kinds of academic things
that might get you up to speed for this
program
um but again
this is really intended as a program for
working professionals
um so I don't want to discourage you
from applying but I do want you
if you contact ask us at simplylearn.net
to have that conversation with learning
consultant make sure that you this is
something that will give you the value
you need
um
we as I mentioned before don't want to
enroll you if it's not going to be a
good fit for you or if it's going to be
at all frustrating or if you find at the
end of the program that you don't have
the
background or experience to apply these
knowledge so I hope that answers that
question for you
um
what's up here are we going to complete
this today only
uh this one webinar is a one-hour
webinar it will be over shortly and
the program itself is a four-month
program I'm not sure if I understood the
question properly but
um
you don't have a time limit on
you have to rush over to ask us to
Simply learn.net enroll today we
do urge you to rush over to
simplylearn.net or ask us at
simplylearn.net and inquire today but
you have
time to understand what the program is
and if it meets your needs
um I hope I understood that question
properly
okay
uh
okay uh says he's not yet interested in
starting because he doesn't have
foundations for machine learning
um
and
the one thing I can say about that is
that
um this program gives you foundations
and machine learning if you have
the mathematics background to be able to
understand the concepts that are being
presented so it's not that you have to
come in with machine learning
understanding
um you don't even have to come in with
the programming recommended recommended
Matlab experience but
um
this is intended to give people
an a kind of grounding machine learning
Concepts that said that can decide how
and whether to apply them in your
organization so wouldn't necessarily be
afraid of starting if you don't have a
machine learning background
um because this is that's the intent of
this program
what happens if you don't know Matlab so
excuse me to him
um
so
the answer to that is you'll get exposed
to that through the program
there are also other research resources
that simple and can provide for you to
help you get exposed to that but you
won't necessarily
need to have extensive knowledge of that
in order to be able to succeed and
benefit from this course
so
you know I hope that answers your
question
should we enroll in a course in Matlab
first you can do that concurrently
um
I would
want to ask your instructor how much
background you
you really need to have in that in order
to complete course one
um
and
again there are resources that will
allow you to
take a primer or a refresher in Matlab
as part of the program we're
concurrently with the program
uh and how does the 100
198 dollars 100 198 dollars per month
work but what that is is an installment
plan it pays off the
2375 over time so that's about a 12
month period
12 monthly payments that total up to the
2375 roughly and
um
you've paid off the program so rather
than paying one lump sum up front you
pay it off in a 12 equal installments
how long does the review process take it
should not take long at all usually we
give an answer within a couple of days
um so again the prereq prerequisites for
this program are fairly straightforward
we don't have to go deep into looking
into your background or that type of
thing some of our programs require
um
a bachelor's degree
in a particular field with a particular
grade point average
so for those we have to do a little more
extensive looking into your transcripts
and that type of thing but for this
program it's much simpler
um
this program so
I have an email address another name but
Bando this is uh asks if the program
leveraged developments and Matlab r or
Python and it focuses mainly on Python
and Matlab or machine learning
um
although RR is an important tool in data
science machine learning um this program
focuses on a more basic skills so that
you don't have to go into
a lot of coding
what type of Technologies
ah so what type of technologies will
this program go over and what is the
advantage for working software
professionals
so again this program is
oriented towards understanding the
fundamentals of machine learning
and how it applies
these cases how it's been used in
different to solve different problems so
that you can gain insights on how you
might use it to solve problems in your
organization
if you want to go deeper into the
inner workings of machine learning and
become a developer or engineer in the
field there are other programs that are
more suitable for that
so you might want to contact ask us at
simplylearn.net and ask that question
about what your goals are
and what specific skills you want to
take out of a learning program
ah
is there an exam template for the tests
in step two
um Rashida I don't believe I've got that
available but I'm not sure that uh
you're going into in the course two
you're doing case studies
um
not sure if the format includes
extensive uh testing
because you're not really learning
skills you're learning about how things
how different problems were solved with
machine learning techniques
but I would again ask our learning
consultant
um see if they might be able to help you
with that or get information from
the professors about that
um
what are the specifics of mathematics
and statistics previously required to
apply to this program I would ask for
folks the learning Consultants but
um so machine learning is based on
being able to
look at a data set
understand the underlying
statistical
principles that govern that data
what type of distribution it falls into
for example
and then to understand the models
modeling techniques that apply to
different data distributions so you need
to have that level of statistical
understanding
basic course and statistics
calculus I don't think you need linear
algebra
so again ask that question
and ask us at simplylearn.net
when is the program offered the program
is offered uh
relatively uh on a every month or every
other month
basis a new cohort starts
um and again it's a four-month program
so the
start and end dates overlap
learning Consultants will be able to
help you with that looking at must you
have python coding knowledge no you
don't have to have a programming
background
in order to take this
particular program
it can help
as mentioned in the prerequisites it's
useful to have
Python Programming and Matlab
programming or
ability to use Matlab but um
it's not a requirement for the course
again you can get
um
supplemental material or supplemental
studies that will help you get up to
speed as much as you need to
uh
Abdul Rahman asked I want to be a
computer vision engineer and I want
resources study for computer vision
um and if you want to be a computer
vision engineer of the Roman probably
and look at some of the other programs
that we have that will take you more
into the internals the engineering and
development behind Ai and ml techniques
um
so you might want to ask our learning
Consultants what's what kind of course
might be more appropriate for that
deeper level of technical understanding
um
getting down to the last few questions
here
uh so Blaze has Java and our background
um
do not require a path now you ask if you
require path python or r
um
so again this is going to be less
emphasis on programming uh you don't
have to have an R background
um python might be useful but it's not
required
um so
that's
um
but you should view that as a impediment
ah
so somebody anonymously asked I've
already completed the master's program
in data science from simpler what are
the topics that this program will cover
which are different from the master's
program
that's a great question
um
so the master's program that you took uh
did dig deep into uh
the tools and techniques and
ability to develop
um looking at different
data modeling techniques building a
solution around those
so you've got that kind of deeper
understanding of the internals and the
workings of data science with some
exposure to machine learning in that
program
um
this program
looks at a bit more of the
ex a little more extensively into what
are the different pieces that go into
machine learning but it especially goes
into use cases and how to apply machine
learning to different real world
problems so that's I think where you
would find most of the value for you is
in
relating what you learned in the data
science program
to how to turn that into Solutions and
machine learning be able to see
well for these types of problems this is
where I would
apply machine learning this is how I
would do it the kind of modeling
techniques I would use and because you
have the background from the data
science master's program you're probably
in a good position than to be able to
actually scope out
and specify how to build those Solutions
excuse me
what's that
okay
Christian I asked uh already working as
a software professional
TCS
how will this program be useful for
improving technical skill set
so again if you are looking to learn
the programming techniques and other
specific engineering techniques to go
into machine learning so that you become
a machine learning engineer this is not
necessarily the program you want to take
but
um
if you are looking to understand the
technology and how to apply it
this is a great program for you
and I think that covers all the
questions basically that we have today
all the time that we have
um I'm going to go ahead
move to our last poll question
that
I share my screen
so if you're in this program
do you need our assistance to get
started now
uh or do you have all the tools and
information you need
let us know
foreign
numbers are stabilized so we're going to
show the answer
about half of you said you would like
help please contact us and ask us
simplywin.net I'm gonna um
share a couple more quick questions that
came in through our LinkedIn audience
uh
one one more question I want to ask
which is uh are there Endeavors to
democratize machine learning
um and so Roland if I understand that
question
um
the uh the answer is yes there's efforts
underway to
um provide open source machine learning
tools and and
efforts there's efforts to make machine
learning
tools models available
through software as a service platform
as a service
so um
there are a lot of efforts to make it
possible for
more people to take advantage of machine
learning technology more people to
contribute to it and to help build up
models
they're even I mean as
as peripherally related as it is there's
been things like creating network
computing efforts where people make the
idle time on their desktop computers
available for uh extensive
uh
data analysis for things like the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
so
you can see how that's
providing a
democratized version of the technology
that
many people can
work with
and
contribute to
with that I'm going to conclude our
webinar today I want to thank everybody
who is here
um apologize that we did not have one of
the professors live to discuss with you
the program
um but the
Professor did have to cancel out at the
last moment so I hope I've answered your
questions and giving you a good overview
of the program but again do contact us
at ask us at simplylearn.net
and we will be glad
provide you answers to your questions
help you get enrolled
so we hope we can welcome you into the
learning community
or uh
MIT X pro
and
thank you all for being here into the
chat one last time
the link to the program page and
ask us at simplylearn.net email address
and
that concludes our webinar for today